aujourd'hui dans l'actuelle le premier
jour des soldes avec le temps maussade
qui n'a pas joué en faveur des ventes de
vêtements et de produits d'été et les
ménages qui contrôlent leur budget les
commerçants espèrent que la période sera
faste aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale séance des questions au
gouvernement hier mardi c'était
l'élection du président et la rentrée
officielle pour les députés premières
impressions la fête médiévale à
saint-cyr-l'ecole un beau succès avec au
programme joutes combats à l'épée et
surtout présentation de rapaces c'est la
fin de saison pour les lieux culturels
et le moment de présenter les programmes
à venir au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'accent sera
mis sur la musique fil conducteur de la
prochaine saison
la chasse aux bonnes affaires est
ouverte depuis 8h ce matin ce sont les
soldes d'été alors selon un sondage
ipsos 77% des français affirment ne pas
vouloir manquer ce grand rendez vous
annuel avec néanmoins un budget en
baisse 1 223 euros en moyenne par
personne contre 259 euros l'an passé à
la même période alors où en est on à la
mi journée mais nous sommes allés faire
un tour au centre commercial de plaisir
pour discuter un peu avec les
commerçants et les acheteurs c'est parti
franchement laissé paradis je
m'attendais à un peu moins de monde et
en fait ça ça tourne mal même carrément
bien on sent que voilà les gens ont peur
de tout acheter vraiment peur et cela
joue beaucoup plus au centre mais les
magasins ne compte pas que sur les
soldes pour écouler leurs invendus
quelques semaines avant le jour j
plusieurs enseignes ont organisé des
ventes privées pour leurs clients les
plus fidèles parmi les clients du jour
on retrouve ceux qui décidément ne s'en
sortent pas j'ai horreur de faire les
soldes
je lui trouve jamais rien qui nous
conviennent
je me fais toujours avoirs et ceux qui
ont des idées bien arrêtées sur ce
qu'ils cherchent qu'est ce que tu
voudrais en particulier
bon démarrage également à l'espace saint
quentin on les clients ont été
accueillis ce matin avec un petit
déjeuner alors les commerçants frappe
fort un -30 -40
-50% dès le début des soldes comme dans
ce magasin de chaussures écouter la
responsable c'est beaucoup mieux que
l'année dernière on et on a vraiment de
la chance puisque cette année on a du
soleil du coup pas ça fait venir le
monde et les gens vraiment beaucoup plus
envie d'acheter selon la direction de
l'espace saint quentin un peu plus de
50000 personnes sont venues profiter des
bonnes affaires ce mercredi soit une
hausse d'environ 60% par rapport à une
période normale le centre commercial
sera ouvert ce dimanche quand des soldes
le 31 juillet
la rentrée parlementaire a eu lieu mardi
26 juin et s'est clos avec l'élection du
président de l'assemblée nationale
claude bartolone les yvelines compte dix
députés de droite sur 12,9 ump et un
radical ils vont désormais siéger dans
l'opposition
dans quel état d'esprit en temps utile
cette nouvelle législature chaque
décision chaque projet de loi
devront être scrutée vraiment à la loupe
dans le détail c'est vraiment du
perfectionnisme on va jusqu'au bout du
détail est justement isolé et déterminer
les vraies réelles conséquences pour les
citoyens parce qu'aujourd'hui ce à quoi
on assiste c'est on envoie de la fumée
et puis on masque derrière la réalité
nous allons être une opposition
constructive bien sûr mais d'abord
vigilante parce que moi je suis très
inquiète des 20 milliards de dépenses
non financées qui ont été annoncés par
françois hollande pour les législatives
et donc je crains que la facture soit
très lourde à payer pour les français
certes la situation politique est
différente mais un parlementaire ça doit
à parler travailler ça doit défendre ses
convictions ça doit être présent et que
ça soit dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition à mon avis ce sera pour
beaucoup parmi les deux députés
socialistes du département l'un ministre
c'est benoît hamon chargé de l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui ne siègera donc
pas dans l'hémicycle son suppléant jean
philippe mallet assurera ses fonctions
et sera investi prochainement
equi
eq co2 bavol qui sur les oiseaux que
bien ici derrière moi qu'ils sont
appelés des buses de harris plus
communément autour mexicains ou alors il
ya les ados diderot vols qui sont ici
comme le faucon lanier c'est difficile à
dresser ce qui m'anime tous les animaux
en règle générale sont difficiles qu'il
faut sept patients et bien savoir
comment s'y prendre à partir de ce
moment là c'est comme un cheval si on on
veut obtenir par la force on ne fera
jamais rien donc c'est toujours par la
douceur dans la patience et le savoir
faire un savoir faire qui impressionne
les visiteurs massés autour de l'enclos
de laurent cette capacité à boire dans
tes dents que cette nature sauvage des
animaux qui en principe il à l'air libre
qui sont ces savoirs à gérer aussi aller
dans tes en fer
utilisèrent de leur forte capacité de
chasse à des fins personnelles j'te côté
mais c'est génial tout ce à quoi les
oiseaux de laurent sont avant tout
destinés au cinéma selon le dresseur le
métier de fauconnier est en pleine
expansion une bonne nouvelle pour les
rapaces la reproduction en captivité
permet en effet de participer à la
préservation des espèces en voie
d'extinction les médiévales l'occasion
également pour le public d'assister à
des tournois et d'en apprendre un peu
plus sur le quotidien des seigneurs et
des chevaliers par exemple en période de
guerre alors en soit marc langlois et
sur notre territoire puisque je défends
le comté de toulouse et malheureusement
nous sommes en sous-effectif et j'ai
bien peur que nous perdions le contest
en entier et sous peu l'aquitaine est
déjà tombée des figurants et des
cascadeurs professionnels ou bénévoles à
100% dans leur rôle pour le plus grand
plaisir des visiteurs venus nombreux
samedi pour plonger dans l'histoire le
temps d'un après midi
bientôt l'été les spectacles de fin de
saison la part belle mais le mois de
juin rime aussi avec nouvelle saison le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines a
récemment présenté sa programmation pour
2012 2013 à la saison prochaine y aura
beaucoup de couleurs et on les a mis sur
la plaquette donc la danse et du théâtre
et de musique
une saison jeune public qui sera qui
sera forte aussi la musique c'est un peu
le fil rouge de la saison une
programmation pluridisciplinaire où la
musique occupera une place importante
plus de la moitié des spectacles fait
appel à des musiciens sur scène ou dans
la fosse d'orchestre les créations aussi
seront privilégiés ont participé à des
créations comme la mouette par exemple
festival d'avignon qui va répéter en
partie d'un théâtre est con on est con
accueillir la saison prochaine mais on
peut citer aussi le roi pêcheur la
création de vincent courtois ou
complètement toqué la création de berne
field et l'associé des musiciens des des
grands chefs cuisiniers à noter
également l'ouverture de saison assuré
par le chorégraphe angelin prejlocaj qui
présentera sa création ce que j'appelle
oublie un spectacle qui s'inscrira dans
la biennale de danse de lyon événements
de renom international il sera un peu
l'invité d'honneur ce qui va venir en
clôture de saison aussi avec un grand
ballet qui s'appelle les mille et une
nuits et c'est vrai que ça va être
quelque chose de marquant pour ce qu'on
veut blanche neige par exemple ici c'est
assez sidérant de voir le style de
chorégraphies de tanger après je cache
quand il se déploie surtout le surtout
sur toute la scène
la saison 2012 s'achèvera avec le cirque
ou cirque heures un cirque e suédois
encore méconnu à mi chemin entre tim
burton et la famille addams à découvrir
d'urgence sylvain groud chorégraphe
associé au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines amènera
spectateurs et danseurs amateurs à
participer à différents projets
présentés lors de la prochaine saison
sur une année 80 projets pédagogiques
sont menées dans les écoles du primaire
au secondaire le nombre de spectateurs
quant à lui est en hausse passant de 58
à 63 milles comme quoi l'art ne connaît
pas la crise
les enfants guyancourt toit de l'école
sonia delaunay travaille depuis quatre
mois sur ce projet leur mission réaliser
les bruitages d'un compte c'est
aujourd'hui le grand jour fini les
répétitions place à l'enregistrement une
espèce de tuyaux
bouteille avec
des papiers un pot de yaourt et une
cuillère daily show avec des lots tous
ces objets manipulés par les élèves de
ce2 et cm2 ont servi à créer des sous
pour illustrer une histoire cette
histoire c'est celle d'un loup très
méchant qui terrorise sa femme et ses
enfants et sachez qu'ils leur conf le
fort
tout le mois de janvier en fin de compte
c'est eux qui ont lu le livre dont
qu'ils avaient on avait dix livres dans
la classe et tous les soirs il repartait
avec le livre et ils n'ont lu au cours
du mois de janvier au moins quatre ou
cinq fois et ensuite on l'a travaillé on
a expliqué ce qu'on cherchait à faire
comme son et à quel moment et pourquoi
après la théorie la pratique aidé par
une conseillère pédagogique les enfants
se sont approprié les instruments pour
accompagner le compteur les écoliers
n'assure pas que les bruitages puisqu'il
signe aussi la musique en chantant une
berceuse pour les louveteaux
l'aboutissement de leur travail se
traduit par les prises de sons avec un
professionnel
le gros du travail maintenant ça va être
de faire le montage
de tout ça c'est à dire qu'on a fait des
prises on en fait beaucoup de prises
parce qu'une heure et au final il y aura
que 20 minutes donc il ya deux micros
pour les élèves les 25e et le micro pour
le côté un peu disproportionné mais
on a besoin d'eux dans son global et
surtout pour les ambiances une activité
ludique et enrichissante
beaucoup d'écouté de concentration
l'analyse d'un texte parce qu'il a fallu
quand même aussi bien le comprendre pour
pouvoir savoir ce qu'on allait faire
derrière et puis voilà
le fait de travailler tous ensemble
l'album intitulé terrible écrit par
l'auteur et éditeur alain serres ainsi
que la bande sonore seront remis aux
élèves de cp à la rentrée prochaine